l'économie n'a pas dit où les lacunes de
la vie à sa mort et qui l'a dit c'est
qu'elle labour and in the money and haas
termine alors et shakespeare à molière
enfin pour force de l'aude avec la
musique il a déjà tenu en laisse de
marbre
donc je suis très content parce qu'en
fait par un pur je dirais hasard ou sur
un député en anglais ce qui vient de se
passer maintenant exactement le sujet
sur lequel je voulais parler et donc le
sujet était daz information technology
remake housewives easy et peut être que
j'irai un peu plus loin je vais
extrapolés pour dire est ce que la
technologie en général tels que la colle
et aujourd'hui vraiment rend notre vie
plus facile
qui d'entre vous pensent que oui la
technologie nous rend la vie facile qui
disent que non et qui disent que
peut-être pas je serai avec vous mais je
vais essayer aujourd'hui de changer
votre avis mon objectif ici tu es dans
15 minutes donne une autre vision des
choses
d'abord la technologie à la base y
compris celle de l'information était
fait pour résoudre des problèmes de spa
notamment ce qu'on appelle rendre les
choses simples alors je voudrais essayer
de donner une définition de la
simplicité d'emploi city est partout
cause
on a deux objectifs le premier ses
victimes
promo réfléchir 6 essayer de résoudre
des problèmes d'avoir des résultats en
utilisant un minimum de ressources
notamment le temps et le deuxième par
conséquent c'est d'avoir beaucoup plus
de temps pour nous mêmes et faire
d'autres choses à l'extérieur notre
travail l'expert de la technologie et de
tout ce qu'on fait au quotidien donc
simple et city dans ma définition si
vous le permettez à deux éléments un est
purement technologique et l'autre là
rien à voir avec théologie cependant ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui en termes
d'information de technologie
d'information nous avons effectivement
résoudre
problème on parle de collaboration
security artificial intelligence vêtu a
appris la société un nouveau niveau mis
un gros problème c'est que est ce que
vraiment tout ce qu'on a fait en
technologie va résoudre les problèmes
vérité où ça va rajouter d'autres
problèmes parce qu'à mon sens qu'il ya
aujourd'hui on est passé d'une itt
thuram a été solutions to its coulé très
vite et vous avez whatsapp vous avez
snap chat vous avez d'autres chocs viber
vous en avez besoin de tous les trois
et pourquoi vous les avez donc on est
passé à this could save est hélas encore
problème parce que au delà de ça ce sera
mais en fait j'ai pas le choix parce que
c'est un banc de l'escudo si je vais
avoir cela il va falloir que j'ai cela
aussi et je suis dans une situation je
peux pas en sortir
et dès le coup je me retrouve accro je
le fais malheureusement la première des
choses le matin je vends un email mon
facebook directement de mon lit
smartphones et vous faites de même
probablement et là il ya un engrenage on
fait un engrenage c'est qu'on va créer
des choses dont on n'avait pas besoin
alors qu'au début on cherchait la
simplicité des choses et on va rentrer
dans un système de complexité spontanée
du fait que en fait non j'ai besoin de
faire de cela et ça devient ça fait
partie presse de mon adn
je me rappelle la première fois quand
j'avais un ordinateur sur ma table
c'était un commodore en 1986 était prête
à lens avec une cassette et mon fils de
3 aujourd'hui paraît que téléphoner je
sais même pas comment il le fait mais
voilà c'est la vérité alors imprimé chez
technologies adtnt sur le soft
complexity par exemple il ya de cela
deux jours je suis allé sur internet et
j'ai mis combien y at il des
utilisateurs facebook en algérie la
réponse
il y avait un million cent cinquante
mille réponses la première est
intéressant mais la deuxième je sais pas
si le voyez c'est peaches mystérieuse
tueuse par le british council en algérie
ça veut dire quoi si je recherche
d'informations aujourd'hui qu'ils soient
si je vais trouver elles tellement
d'informations et qu'est-ce que
faire je vais passer beaucoup plus de
temps à essayer de trouver quelle est
l'information la plus importante pour
moi
mais ce n'était pas ce qui devait être
fait par l'information technology
je pense que c'est ça le but n'est ce
pas après avoir passé un autre fléau
et là c'est un problème je veux dire est
un peu éthiques
les choix que nous avons aujourd'hui
sont très souvent imposée on nous impose
ses choix
pourquoi parce que les grandes
compagnies technologiques sont passés du
mode je vais résoudre un problème je
vais vous aider
un mode où il va falloir vous achetez
plus si aprilia cette guerre des prix
des gars de produits et on se retrouve
au niveau des organisations avec des
problèmes d'intégration security chez
nous
en fait quand c'est l'abattement n'est
donc encore une fois la science s'est
déplacée et a laissé le concept approach
to put rimonim making machine
oui c'est sûr
mike froman ajiq de technologie d'avoir
ce poste où elle passe c'était ça le but
maintenant c'est du micro management de
la technologie qui devait nous aider
et alors j'ai besoin de 48 heures toutes
les 24 heures pour résoudre des
problèmes haïti et d'autres technologies
je ne vais pas m'étaler parler d'autres
problèmes que la technologie a causé le
réchauffement planétaire
la pollution et line humanisme
on n'est plus connecté on parle plus et
les gens sont revenus au bercail
votre approche la guerre on résout pas
le problème on va créer d'autres là
alors quand on a beaucoup de choix
qu'est ce qui va se passer on a plus de
symbiose de synergies on a trop de choix
et là des îles hawaï dans la formation
des systèmes qui ne peuvent pas
communiquer nous avons aussi du contenu
qui n'est pas le même
vous avez travaillé sur des projets et
d'un coup vous avez perdu par exemple la
dernière version et à la panique
générale et on sait pas ce qu'on doit
faire
oh mon dieu j'ai créé de fastweb et ça
se produit dans de grandes compagnies
aient compris des banques
vous imaginez pourquoi parce que la
promesse de technologie qui va m'aider à
faire tout n'a pas été en fait mise à l
épreuve réellement alors maintenant je
vais passer quelque chose de plus
intéressant qui est donc l'intérêt daft
punk c'est beau c'est extraordinaire
cisco récemment avec qui j'ai eu le
président travailler dans l'impasse et a
prédit que durant les cinq prochaines
années aura romain ces milliards
d'objets connectés 5 milliards d'objets
connectés ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
5 milliards d'objets excusez mon le
terme stupide non intelligent qu'on va
essayer de les mettre en contact pour
qu'il soit intelligent
ok alors je vais acheter ma pizza et
d'un seul coup j'ai ma balance au niveau
de ma salle de bains kibio tu vas aulas
pourquoi parce qu'en fait pourquoi parce
que ma smartphones avec lequel je vais
payer a envoyé un message semble le dire
parce que ma femme en fait la programmer
et puis voilà je me retourne je peux pas
prendre pizza ça a l'air d'être
simpliste grigolo mais ça peut se
produire ça va se produire quand on
donne autorité à des objets pourparlers
sur lesquels on a aucune aucun pouvoir
eh ben on va tomber dans des situations
un peu bizarre et là ça me pose un
problème je dirais même éthique
ce sera le plus grand fax fiasco de
micro management dans l'histoire de
l'humanité lorsqu'on passera en force
dans l' internet orthez parce que là on
parle pas d'objets seulement les objets
rang des procédures des procédés les
humains autour de ça et même je dire
q le futur de l'humanité va en dépendre
imaginez le métro d'alger sur le
conducteur internet en france avec le
bus qui communiquent mais qui
communiquent pas bien avec notre taxi
qui vient de l'autre côté
eh ben mon s'échapper avec l'algérie
peut-être un sol vers calais naga quatre
ans comme aller jouer mon nom c'est par
et alors ce qui se passe en fait c'est
ce concept de choix qui est très lourd
sur nous et il faut vraiment vous en
tant qu'étudiants et demain j'espère
vous aurez des l'opportunité de
développer des solutions réelles pour la
société à ne pas tomber dans l'engrenage
des baies corporation dans le sens où
nous sommes les leaders mondiaux de ce
si cela d'accord il faut vraiment rendre
à l'être humain à la société ce qui lui
est de droit est vrai grâce et bien on
va à l'encontre du principe fondamental
pour lequel la technologie existe qui
est être au service de l'humanité elle
ne l'est plus malheureusement je n'ai
vraiment pas besoin que ma voiture soit
connecté avec mon téléphone mon
téléphone avec mon frigo mon fric avec
le vélo de ma fille mal pourquoi
pourquoi tant de complexité alors qu'au
début moi je voulais travailler moins
d'heures je veux travailler trois heures
par jour si vous le permettez et le rêve
passer du temps avec mes enfants avec
mes amis j'allais voir des papillons de
voir la mer pourquoi je vais être
cloîtré dans une entreprise et travaillé
vingt heures par jour pour souci de
productivité parce que vous avez les
moyens avant mais je pensais que si je
veux technologie intelligente je vais
travailler moi ah non non il faut revoir
il faut faire ceci ceci cela et parce
qu'on a recruté et parce que entre
guillemets l'accès à ces technologies
entre guillemets intelligent tu vas te
donner le temps de travailler plus vous
connaissez la blague du celui qui
travaille qu'une brouette il y avait 2
et quand le chef de chantier venu pour
payer il a dit des crimes avril elf quel
os m
deutsche bank ils travaillent plus que
toi est ce qui va se passer
éventuellement dans la technologie plus
vous avez d'une hausse du bruit ça veut
dire que ça marche il ya de l'effort
donc en fait le but de mon intervention
aujourd'hui c'est de m'adresser à vous
qui êtes la nouvelle génération
je suis pas anciens jeux mais qui est la
génération qui va influencer le futur de
ce pays du reste texte ça va être au
niveau international les jeunes qui a
parlé juste à venise et week-end et new
generation est bien sûr sortait du
concept géographique et tous vous êtes
ce que vous souhaitez être and we make
our future
il est très important que l'on se
recentre sur notre ambition est le rôle
du savoir que nous avons acquis et
pourquoi on va l'utiliser ne tombe et
surtout pas sous la notion de ce que
j'appelle authorize c'est à dire je vais
faire du out sur le stick de ma façon de
réfléchir et on va me dire quand je dis
mot progrès ouais mais on peut
progresser vers la guerre on peut
progresser vers des catastrophes aussi
progrès ne veut pas dire essentiellement
bien ou croissance en ces beaux sur la
croissance économique et la croissance
économique veut dire aux rayons gamma
sur les ressources qu'on ne peut pas
ramener le pib que c'est beau ce mot pib
c'est bien mais cette société a une
énorme demande de divorce de criminalité
parce que même un prêt bancaire fait
partie aussi de l'équation monétaire
donc il va falloir que vous vous
recentrer ce soit information technology
article janeiro make sure that you know
what i call schiphol qui c'est qui a dit
des brebis quelqu'un parler de brebis je
viens d'inventer un modèle chip brebis
pipeau pipeau
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont des
chiffons
ça veut dire quoi chico ça veut dire ils
vont de l'avant ils sont tous quand on
voit la boîte waraba dah est europe pour
toi parce que leur a dit que c'est ça le
futur
it's beautiful en dehors de side ok donc
je ne pourrais pas dire que la
technologie et l'information et la
technologie d'information et mauvaises
non loin de là je suis là on est là
c'est à cause de cela mais il ya le
facteur humain c'est à nous d'avoir
cette responsabilité éthique de revoir
notre comportement nos choix et si on
n'achète pas si on prend pas ces
solutions
eh bien je pense que sais-je en avant
éventuellement changer de cap vous
connaissez tous
l'impact que l'open source technologies
a eu sur les sites web mozilla combien
de vous utilisez firefox pas mal comparé
l internet explorer mais c'est gratuit
et puis vous avez des panoplie de
solutions j'ai même mis au repos qui
sont open source qui n'ont aucun
problème si ce genre d'attitude qui va
falloir adopter
c'est ce que j'appelle alternatives
telles quelles alternatives attitude
soyez soyant différents pour un futur
meilleur pour toute l'humanité
et vous avez tous le moyen de le faire
parce que y'a personne qui est quoi que
ce soit de plus que vous parce que vous
construisez comme votre futur comme je
vais dire donc je compte sur vous pour
me joindre
ne serait-ce que sur la pensée en
général mais si on le fait petit à petit
on peut réussir et qui sait peut-être
que d'ici un jour on entendra parler des
solutions qui seraient humans entre